حيث اعلنت الشرطه البريطانيه انها عثرت
على ثلاثه قتلى في مدينه نوتنهام بواسطه
انجلترا والقت القبض على شخص مشتبه به في
الحادث واوضحت الشرطه انها اعتقلت رجلا
يبلغ الحاديه والثلاثين من عمره بشبهه
محاوله القتل بعد العثور على ثلاثه قتلى
في المدينه بينما تم نقل ثلاثه اخرين الى
المستشفى وكانت الشرطه قد اعلنت صباح
اليوم انها تتعامل مع حادث خطير حيث طوقت
وسط المدينه مع استدعاء سيارات الاسعاف
والاطفاء الى المكان في حين حثت هيئه
النقل العام السكان على ايجاد طرق بديله
للتنقل في انتظار الانتهاء من التحقيقات
عن هذه الصور مباشره تاتينا الان من
نوتنجهام لهذا الطوق الامني الذي فرضته
الشرطه بعد اعتقال مشتبه به في قتل ثلاثه
اشخاص
بحادثين واصابه ثلاثه في محاوله دهس
بشاحنه في نوتينغهام في بريطانيا
في الساعه الاخيره ولم تكن الشرطه
البريطانيه قد ذكرت تفاصيل اكثر بخصوصه
لكن الحصيله على ما يبدو ثلاثه قتله
واصابات ايضا في هذين الحادثين في محاوله
درس واعتقلت الشرطه كما تقول مشتبها به في
الحاديه والثلاثين من عمره من حربلو
متواجده في لندن لتطلعن على اخر التفاصيل
التي لديك منها
ثقلت رجلا بشبهه القتل بعد العثور على
ثلاثه اشخاص
في المدينه تم الابلاغ عن هذا
القفل شخصين في الساعه الرابعه صباحا من
اليوم في احد يعني النواحي من من المدينه
تم الابلاغ عن مقتل عن شخص قتيل في
الناحيه اخرى من نفس المدينه وسط المدينه
ثم تم الابلاغ عن محاوله بعث من قبل سياره
فان لثلاثه اشخاص هم الان حسب الشرطه
يتلقون العلاج في المستشفى الشرطه الشرطه
تقول بان شخصا يبلغ من العمر 31 عاما ثم
اعتقاله بشبه القتل ويبقى قيد الاعتقال في
مخفر الشرطه احد المتحدثين
عن الشرطه قال من الشرطه قال بان هذه
الحادثه المروعه والماساويه اودت بحياه
ثلاثه اشخاص وان الشرطه تعتقد بان الحوادث
الثلاث مرتبطه ببعضها البعض وان يعني
الشخص مازال قيد الاعتقال ضمن تحقيقاتها
التي تقول بانها في بداياتها وان فريق
المحققين يعمل من اجل تقصي الحقائق
الحقائق وما حدث تحديثا تحديدا في هذه
العمليه
ودعت الشرطه البريطانيه
عامه او بقيه سكان المدينه الى الصبر
وتوخي الحذر في انتظار استمرار تحقيقاتها
في هذا الوقت في الوقت الراهن وان عدد من
الطرق ستبقى مغلقه لكن بحسب ما علمناه
وشاهدناه من الناس الذين
يمشون في الشوارع يبدو ان هناك نوع من
الهدوء ان صح التعبير كان الناس تريد ان
تعود لنشاطها كالمعتاد ربما لانهم يشعرون
بانه ليس هناك ما يؤثر على ما يشكل خطر
على حياتهم الملاحظه جلال ان الشرطه
البريطانيه لن تستبق كما
في حوادث سابقه التحقيقات وتؤكد يعني بان
هذه العمليه ربما هي عمليه ارهابيه او
محاوله ارهابيه من قبل شخصنا لكن يبدو
انها تعرفت على هويه هذا الشخص الذي تعتقد
بانه هو منفذ هذه العمليات سواء عمليات
القتل للشخصين في
لثلاثه اشخاص او محاولات
قبلنا ان الشخص الذي القت القبض عليه هو
الذي نفذ العمليه الاولى وقتل شخصين ثم
نفذ العمليه الثانيه وقتل شخصا ثم اصاب
ثلاثه اخرين ما الذي قالته عنها عدا كونه
يبلغ من العمر 31 عاما
حتى الساعه مريم الشرطه لا زالت تقول بان
هذه التحقيقات في بداياتها المبكره ولا
يمكنها ان تتحدث عن شيء اكثر في انتظار
هذه التحقيقات التي قالت بان المحققين من
عناصر الشرطه يواصلون يعني يحاولون تحديد
تحديد ما حدث فعلا فيما يتعلق بهذه
الحادثه لكن ما علمناه بان التواجد الامني
المكثف وايضا تطوير مناطق واسعه من الوسط
المدينه كان من اجل التاكد بانه هناك يعني
بان هذه العمليه مقتصره على وسط المدينه
بحسب البلاغات التي وصلت الى الشرطه رغم
ان كثير من الاشخاص في المدينه لم يكونوا
يعلموا بهذه العمليه عمليه القتل التي
حصلت وكثير منهم كان يتحدث عن ان الشبكه
مثلا الثوم وقد تم تعليفها في بسب ربما
اسوء الاحوال الجويه ليله امس لكن الاشخاص
الذين تحدثوا مبكرا يتحدثون عن وجود عناصر
من الشرطه المسلحه وسط المدينه لكن مريم
كما ذكرت هذه العمليه لا زالت محصوره فيما
يتعلق بشبهه القتل قد لا تكون عمليه امنيه
كما يتوقع البعض وكما شاهدنا من قبل لكن
يبدو انها عمليه خطيره جدا
والشرطه لا زالت يعني في بدايات هذه
التحقيقات لمعرفه ما حدث فعلا وما هي
اهداف هذه العمليه عمليه القتل وما هي
الدوافع وراءها لقتل هؤلاء الاشخاص
الثلاثه ومحاوله قتل الاخرين في نفس
المدينه في شوارع متفرقه والضواحي ونواحي
متفرقه من المدينه